the last outspoken political opponent of
russia's president appeared in a prison
courtroom in a black prison uniform
looking gaunt
the judge found alexey navalny guilty of
fraud and contempt of court the sentence
nine years jail in a maximum security
prison
when navalny spoke the video feed from
the courtroom to journalists was cut so
his supporters posted his comments
online
you can't put everyone in prison even if
you ask for 113 years you won't scare me
or others like me every person must act
in their own way as they can considering
the circumstances but act
as navalny's lawyers spoke outside the
prison police with loud hailers tried to
drown them out
of course we will appeal the verdict we
were not able to use a recording device
or have digital copies of the case
papers so this was incorrect procedure
on top of the fact that it was taking
place in the prison which is very rare
it's just over a year since alexei
navalny returned to russia from germany
he'd been given medical treatment after
a poison attack with a nerve agent
during a visit to siberia
within minutes of his plane landing
navalny was arrested he's not been out
of jail since
navalny was russia's main opposition
leader he tried to run for president in
the election in 2018 but was barred from
standing
his anti-corruption foundation was
declared an extremist organization and
shut down
then in february last year navalny was
jailed for two and a half years for
parole violations charges he says were
trumped up to silence him
this is
not a surprise that
putin would like to keep alexey in
prison for as long as he is in power
we are completely sure that this is his
direct order to
imprison alexey
there were demonstrations in several
russian cities against navalny's
treatment particularly after he went on
hunger strike there's little chance of
anything like this this year
[Applause]
any recent attempts to protest against
the war in ukraine have been snuffed out
before they started
alexei navalny tried to keep up his
campaigning from prison with his lawyers
posting messages on instagram but that's
now banned here and with navalny being
moved to a maximum security prison it's
unlikely we're going to hear from him
for many years
bernard smith al jazeera moscow